listen general i like to refer to him as
El Presidente or Monsieur mogul head
honcho head honcho uh Mac Daddy no see
no George yeah that's okay either like
head honcho I always scott coker the
Great Scott Coker president as we call
Scott Bellator I think people call Scott
well by the way and and I I'm not I said
this to you when he came in off the air
I have never heard anything but good
things about you but people forget Scott
bill strike force from remember the US
season the first ones to do this Scott
built strike force basically for nothing
partner of the Showtime and CBS is that
right yeah we had shows on CBS we
brought fate or to fight I think about
so in Cyprus but you know it blew up man
and in four years five years yeah I was
oh actually it was like three years what
you and I mean you're talking about some
of the greatest fights ever oh yeah I
one day when the UFC bought Strikeforce
I remember going ah they were wearing
the t-shirt sound like no we need the
combination your time in Strikeforce
would you say those were kind of not the
glory days cuz after doing big things in
Bellator but I'll tell you what man I
remember everyone tuned into those
fights you know what it was a special
moment in time and it was the end of pro
elite era so they had signed all these
great fighters and we bought proly and
and it's kind of like a double-edged
sword because when when we bought proly
I had to take in a financial partner to
make that acquisition so I brought in
before I own a hundred percent of it
right so we're moving along and we're
doing great gates of a you know HP
pavilion signing big fighters and then
and then this this opportunity comes
along and I said okay well to do this
deal I need to go bring in a partner so
my arena that I was doing fights at
their own by the san jose sharks so I
they approved approaching missing hey
when you when you want to do a deal we
would like to invest with you and so
it's okay now's the time so they put in
a bunch of money they got a percentage
of the company it's actually the equal
percentage right so we went we bought
proly we got Gina Carano and we got you
know Nick Diaz we got
you know me shake shields me no no me
show somebody we found in aterna we had
a tournament but but anyway so we got
about 10 top top talented athletes
world-class athletes and then we
integrated them with our our roster
which was Kong and Frank and Josh
Thompson giver Melendez and then we
started taking off and so that that was
the double-edged sword because with that
deal we got the CBS contract and the
Showtime contract because that's what
they had they had delivered or they had
already acquired though so we had
instantly a showtime deal we went from
doing four fights a year to do in 16
fights a year had to ramp up it was a
great time of growth for the company and
then you know and then that was in 2009
2008 and 2010 you know the UFC knocks on
the door say we'd like to acquire
Strikeforce so how do you organize
because no one else can do it yeah let's
be honest no one else can do it I tell
you it's um you know for 30 years or
thirty one years this is pretty much
what I focused on and you know when I
think about the female fighting we were
promoting female fights back in the 80s
with female kickboxing and it was some
of the best fights these girls could
really fight it wasn't just like we had
girls fighting to fight like some
exploitation these are real skilled
martial arts females look at leisure
Riker yeah look at cafergot anybody make
seven dollars off those fights
especially in a you know it's a real hey
listen I did okay I don't think I did I
did okay well yeah I wasn't bad to me no
but you know it's like with kickboxing
compared to ma you just add a zero yeah
yeah yeah if you lose you lose adizero
if you gain that's that way the game
yeah but but you know I grew up in a
martial arts school with women training
all around me so to me when we had kick
boxing fights and these are some of the
best fighters in the world and there
they came from all over the planet to
come fight in the Bay Area we filmed it
all for ESPN so having females fight was
like was like this one no brand this is
martial arts man you know it's like this
is reality right and so they should be
competing if they want to compare and
with a guy like Roy house I was telling
your boys when they came in we're
talking a little bit about Rory I know
Rory very well trained together
been out on the town together people
think Roy's this introverted like I do
that's how I dc9 that's why I'm telling
like you guys need his he seems that way
he's very calculated he's very smart
he's funny he's actually pretty outgoing
we don't really is I know he really is I
tell you what when I saw him walking
down the ramp I go man this guy feels
really comfortable I could tell he a
little swagger to him said all the right
things and you know he's I think he's
going to do well in Bellator have some
tough fights here I payment daily I
think it would be a great fight I think
him in Lima tough fights all they're all
tough fights yeah and you know but
walking down that ramp you know the
crowd you know just giving him the
accolades that he deserves I said this
is gonna be a great home for him does he
get a title shot right away you know
when yet knows he we haven't even talked
about that but you know it's like I'm
you know whether it's a title shot or
super fight or you know we throw a
170-pound welterweight tournament you
know it's like who knows we have we have
some fun stuff ahead for Rory yeah I was
I was really close close with Kimbo do
you have any good Kimbo stories that
people haven't heard oh boy I tell you
man it's it's uh just hanging out with
that guy was just you know like like no
like he was like a rock star honestly
it's like so close you could everywhere
we went hey kimbo hey kimbo and i didn't
realize it like when he came back it's a
fighting I was like is this guy gonna be
popular you know I didn't know and so we
were in st. Louis and and man he just
got mobbed everywhere he went come
remind me like Bob Sapp in Japan he was
getting mod I think the thing that
always bothered about Kimbo I talked to
his son about this little bit is no one
ever really told his story like you talk
about just hanging out Kimbo he was like
the nicest most down-to-earth humble guy
you you want our judgment book by cover
you just can't yeah like he was just a
family guy was feeding you know feed his
family say hey she runs she's the boss
talk to his wife she's the bomb mother
of six yeah she's the boss and he kept
saying you know I'll go do my thing but
but she's the boss and and you know a
lot people don't realize he went to
university of miami right he was a he
was a he's a football player in the
hurricane
working here kind of changed his life
and but you know smart guy and smart guy
but you know when it when it came time
to do his thing he did his thing I mean
you know it's he was like this you know
just kind of you know was he the
greatest fighter we all know the answer
to that but but really it's like
everybody gravitated towards it I think
he transcended fighting yeah I think
they just pop culture he and not only
that he also was somebody who you
pointed to of what was possible he came
from not such good circumstances and
this here's this guy who literally
fought his way out of the ghetto from
from backyards in Dave County Miami and
think about cure he was the first really
i mean youtube should be paying his
family royalties because you talking
that comfort or else he kicks remember
youtube at the time was in anything and
then they started up on these Kimbo
Slice videos I'm where my mom my aunt's
would like look at this is nuts black
any bites were got a piece on cover 12
cutie pies I feel guys maybe tell lift
your shears
yeah one fighter in the Cuban Brendan
shop Bryan Callen shark eyes dolphin
smiling k right beside ya I challenge
team that you'll catch your me uppercut
Evan de Botton bears if you want to join
the ceiling you have questions asked
sweet advisory kids the lead to
admissions we'll talk about fight the
scourge of this with calendars dropping
house better learn what said now I'll
covered the basics let me get on my case
I'm like Tim Kennedy creepin on up in
Saada age I'll safe I love rap corn the
fire and I'm a rapper they'd rather have
on the tight shots fired high-pitched
light on the city's [ __ ] trunk basildon
read will sasso Sinestro 10 Callan
stealing grinds my gears like my car is
escape or to my ex cut off the pot for
this your paper
boys the greatest 2016 gusta tu speech
rights got me even like cookie dough
please win the battle rapper stack
rounds like the scene of ship named
flips punchlines you have to have a
multi-season schemes the combos
rebuttals to like a counter-puncher
takedown can relate to an angle and
battle rapper personals can make them
choke and habitat and that's a wrap one
last thing support the fighter soon fly
me out Cali man around this is a fighter
my name's came God yeah that's good um
speaking of sports um I i assume you
watch the fuh fuh-fuh-fuh-fuh fight I
did meant so that that's why I was late
to that Hasim Hasan guy sorry if I
messed up his name manoj thing because
the fight started at five or six and
they went fast yeah they did because
they were good so I got seem so I left
the house like 715 got downtown some 40
ish cuz door you know start at eight but
the fights were good you did you get to
see him cuz you in Columbus I did I'm
always worried cool scene was on Fox
night so I watched it back stay in the
back yeah I was very lucky that way um
that pet Pettis looked good and and and
he's been working on his wrestling one
hundred percent but he yeah he gave his
back up a couple times I was very
worried dude I'm telling you like before
tea I try not gonna be biased yeah that
try not to be biased dude I there's
there's two people I was like God dang i
hope they win Paige Vanzant and Anthony
Pettis at that jumping roundhouse kick
whew that karate you talk about the
karate kid I was Holly crying kid to the
face and back stuff his nails but that
this is my I guess the reason why I root
for him so hard again Pettis I know he's
my boy I love Pettis man and he needed a
win so [ __ ] mad page i don't really
know met her once lovely girl brilliant
the sport needs her especially that
weight class but to come off remember
she went on dance with stars finished
second in that competition but prior to
that she lost the fight to rose not only
is she lose she got her a swim yes grant
showed her toughness we like to see that
she didn't look good at all she got
molliwopped then she wasn't dancing
stars so now you have fighter jealousy
you can see people on why she right she
should even be there I don't get how she
even she's a celebrity whoa I get it you
wish you were her it's a big issue
because she didn't perform schema for
loss cuz I'm damn start her star power
gets even bigger right cute little girl
tough as nails now people go and I don't
think she wants to fight she wants to be
celebrity look at her dancing she's not
training blah blah granted that's a
different kind of stamina you know
dancing them [ __ ] monsters watching
that ballroom dancing yeah the
commitment all that so it's a different
type of animal so she's committed that
for however long as three months then
she goes back to training she goes not
all i care about is finding people oh
yeah right then they go okay here's
[ __ ] rowdy back on a [ __ ] fox card
like oh my god this girl needs to win
unless you win but she lyoto machida her
in the face to win I was straight up we
ordered like showed up or shot dude the
pressure she that she must have been on
and you lose that fight and you get to
the back line you're the you're you're
the cute celebrity that wants to try
this yeah you basically CM Punk with six
fights that's right that's of girls but
that was a hell of a haha so happy I'm
so happy for her this is I get it man
when you have that pressure it's just so
insane so insane and then with Patti's
dude I've been there when I lost a node
era and rothwell back to back then at
the time you know is a different day the
UFC was come people if you [ __ ]
sneezed wrong or looked at Joe silver
the wrong way so they're cutting them
like [ __ ] man what's going on and then
you get lavar johnson and just tho na
can do down the first round just with
with mule kick hands and and just it
just guzzling [ __ ] Daris Jocelyn
didn't you say more scene didn't you say
to Dana didn't you go you know he's on
stairs I Wayans I said to everyone we
all know he's on steroids correct and it
was like no it's a team i coach started
laughing go Brendan he's we all know
we're all aware he's on it right in
front of him we're all where he's on
steroids correct and then he walked off
in blah blah blah but uh that fight was
the pressure your honor and remember I
wasn't as big as stars pet's name
enclosure talking about champ yeah the
guy he's WEC champ UFC champ Wheaties
box and goes on the weedy box and goes
on a
[ __ ] losing streak grandys lost on
the best in the world goes on a terrible
losing streak so you've lost three in a
row far out and now you have this
monster in trouble Rivera wrestler ah
man no Charles is a stand-up guy black
belt just not really wrestle really not
a great stand-up good great great he's
coming he kept great stand-up great on
the ground jutsu very dangerous new
weight class 1 45 I thought ah man uh I
don't know what's next friend I'm I'm so
glad he got that win he's that weight
cut for him tough boy his cardio was
tough in that second round is that
what's not from the weight weight loss
yeah really just being dehydrated all
that yeah with no I v2 I don't know who
they toss them next but if they toss him
a grappler that 145 it's tough he's
working his grappling a lot though it
looks like I mean he again I you when
people guys working scrap when he
brought Bryan wrestling coach okay but
you're in the top five that doesn't it
doesn't compute it doesn't work does
that make sense yeah like you have your
skill set you didn't get better and
recognize things and come up with
certain moves that will counter of some
of what they do but when it's their
bread and butter and it's their nature
to take your ass down yeah you're going
gone down it's just what they do where
the [ __ ] is my money Brian all right six
grand I hold that is in the bag bro no
is it in the back I just need a bra okay
I'll get your money your money's right
here I can give it to you it's in the
back that's good coffee I can give you
the money in the bag right now but i
have i have a problem is good coffee i
got a problem my eyes you put it in my
eyes no seriously though man now listen
we're the [ __ ] moment prob listen you
try and triple or nothing I got it I got
a proposition what let me open a
proposition I would he get cuz I mean if
you show your wife feel me six grand I
didn't tell anybody manda yells me six
grand listen bro do you I don't know if
you have the guts for this and if you
don't i get it i'll give you the six
ramp right now all right I just get it
i'll do that i don't want to hear you
problems now i'll just take the six
grand where's that you want a good trip
like nothing over true all or nothing
over what obviously steep a alistar
ovary
it's a man for 12 grand I view the six
right now are you gonna give me 12 grand
if I saw yeah well we even go trouble
another tier I get the first pick but if
you want bro whatever you want you know
what my voice is high like this you know
I'm being sincere is yeah it's not a big
deal i can reject you want this in Skrim
i give it to you right now it's right
there oh we got triple or nothing let's
go trebling nothing go triple enough and
I get first pick i gotta hit the head go
ahead oh yeah take your time take your
time take a couple breaths take a couple
breaths nobody's forcing you into
anything here we're just talking like my
haha Phil you mean honey did get out of
six girl lay it out for you the shakes
claim it's not a big deal for me I don't
care I want to give it to you but if you
want to triple it up God dog such a hard
fight to pick just ripple it ah you want
the six you know i don't i would love
six great i'll give it to you yeah right
oh you get or you can triple or nothing
you know what the promise is I've in
against Seabees my boy I picked against
them and keeps pulling through it's
tough then again i don't want i don't i
don't want al she's been on a tear you
know I don't like you know I don't like
about this fight I don't like Steve a
fighting in some town I don't like that
if it if this fight was in Holland I
pics deep a 100-percent this fight was
in Florida at pics DP this fight was in
Vegas I pics deepening the pressure
might get too steep and he's never find
its home down first time in Cleveland do
you want he's gone to Brazil do you want
to pay calloused no head [ __ ] you know
it's a dialog man I know what stop hey I
they do some major hey nothing's easy
man what's easy you just don't want to
do you throw you out this there's
nothing that's easy am I talking like
that in my eye
I got choked like nothing take Alistair
Alistair is a badass huh certain kick
and he can but as I know he is Elmo's
stick to your guns I know your heart
saying Alan stir your brain is staying
steep a go with your arm know in your
heart all right i'll take steep a house
for 12 grand how you're gonna take house
to know you're sleeping oh yeah for 12
grand double or nothing gives me six
grand we were Double or Nothing the
devil or not yeah gotcha okay what else
you can do is Steve Avery 12 rare I
thought you said you're gonna take
Alistair no let's go gotta force my hand
right now you're the one that told me to
pick you want you i austin know yet ste
pay for 12 grand serve a triple or
nothing